[Music]
during a time when the church controlled
what people could believe and the kings
ruled over what people ought to own
john locke an english doctor popularized
three ideas that changed society and
parenting forever
first people keep fighting over their
beliefs because nobody can actually know
which one is true
to solve this problem everyone should
have freedom of thought and the right to
choose their own religion
[Music]
second kings can't just do as they
please because people have natural
rights to liberty property and life
and hence need to be asked for
permission
[Music]
third
parents should avoid punishing their
children since the use of emotions to
make them behave well can make them
sensationalist
instead they should allow their children
to be guided by thoughts
locke's ideas on religion and democracy
became the foundation of most liberal
societies his thoughts on education
however may have been even more
influential
[Music]
locke understood that most people doubt
new ideas without any other apparent
reason than them being uncommon
however
teaching children how to think
rationally and all for themselves works
education is therefore the key to
freeing society from political and
psychological tyranny and his book some
thoughts concerning education became a
parenting guide to that world
the book was originally written to help
his friends raise their son edward to
become a virtuous adult the ultimate
goal of education
locke defined virtue as a combination of
self-denial and rationality because we
need to control our desires to think
clearly
he proposes four main ideas to help
edward
[Music]
first newborn babies minds are like a
blank slate also known as tabula rasa
all knowledge comes from our perception
which then leaves imprints on that blank
slate
because a child is highly sensitive to
new experiences even the smallest
association of ideas can have lasting
consequences if you let a foolish maid
convince edward the goblins come out at
night darkness shall forever frighten
the boy loch warns
second body and mind develop together
which is why locke advises to nurture
edward's physical needs as much as his
mental ones
he recommends a plain and simple diet
such as dry bread and a small
non-alcoholic beer to make the boys
strong rich or spiced foods should be
avoided as they are too tempting for the
boy's delicate mind
to toughen the young body abundant sleep
on a hard bed is ideal
exposing edward to harsh conditions such
as cold baths protects him from the
common cold
third learning should be pleasant
if children find academic education
exciting and can choose what they like
for themselves they will then apply
themselves to it industriously
to learn reading lock suggests games
this self-directed approach to learning
allows the parents to discover and
nurture their child's natural talents
[Music]
punishment should be avoided as it can
break a child's spirit and it teaches
the wrong values to secure the best
education he urges the parents to hire a
tutor rather than send edward to school
fourth habits always trump rules so
parents should help their children
establish clear routines and aim to
become role models of rational thinking
this will help edward to learn how to
control his desires and think rationally
to become virtuous
locke believed that good habits of
thought prevail while rules which speak
to the heart fail
however habits are important not only
because they trump rules but because
rules consequently lead to rewards and
punishments sensations that arouse
feelings instead of reason
to become a free thinker a rationalist a
child shouldn't be driven by rules or
incentives but by esteem and fear of
disgracing oneself
[Music]
locke's thoughts on education were
published in 1694
and became an international bestseller
along with russo's emile his book became
one of the most influential texts on
educational theory and perhaps history's
most important guide to parenting
john locke once said that reading
furnishes the mind only with materials
of knowledge it is thinking that makes
what we read ours
since the same is true for videos we
recommend creating the habit of short
thinking breaks after watching something
afterwards share your thoughts with
others and in the same way make new
ideas forever yours
try that right now and tell us what you
think of lock's ideas
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com slash sprouts